[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est sens
public votre rendez-vous quotidien de
débat de chronique et de reportage sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 18 octobre la
frappe qui a en partie détruit l'hôpital
Ali arabe de Gaza causant la mort d'au
moins
471 personnes marquent un tournant dans
la guerre qui oppose Israël au
ramas sans avertissement une roquette F1
s'est abattu sur l'hôpital soudain tout
est devenu noir il y avait des corps et
du sang tout autour des têtes ont été
coupées c'est un crime que personne ne
peut imaginer c'est un crime contre
l'humanité les deux camp s'accuse
mutuellement d'être à l'origine de ce
tir meurtrier Joe Biden en visite à TAV
affirme que des données américaines
disculpent l'État hébreux mais devant
l'émotion et les manifestations les
chefs d'états arabes qui devaient
participer à ce sommet en Jordanie en
présence du président américain on
préférait renoncer à ce rendez-vous on
analyse les conséquences de ce carnage
avec nos invités dans une minute et puis
pour notre second débat c'est
l'implosion de la nup que je vous
propose de décortiquer le Parti
socialiste suspend sa participation le
Parti communiste acte l'impasse les ver
crée un nouveau mouvement l'incapacité
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de ses fidèles
de condamner clairement le Hamas comme
une organisation terroriste aura eu
raison de l'union de la gauche peut-elle
renaître sous une nouvelle forme qui
pourrait incarneré l'après Mélenchon on
en débat dans 45 minutes mais d'abord le
bilan et les conséquences de cette
frappe aérienne contre l'hôpital de Gaza
avec Louis
Belin un afflux ininterrompu de blessés
et d'ambulances conséquence d'une frappe
dévastatrice sur un hôpital en plein
centre de Gaza hier soir l'explosion a
fait plusieurs centaines de morts et
provoqué une vague d'indignation et de
colère dans l'ensemble du monde arabe
comme ici en Tunisie immédiatement mise
en cause Israël a nié toute implication
et accuse en retour un allié du Hamas le
Djihad
islamique selon nos renseignements le
Hamas a vérifié les rapports a compris
qu'il s'agissait d'une roquette ratée du
dihad islamique et a décidé de lancer
une campagne médiatique mondiale pour
cacher ce qui s'était réellement
passé une version qui fait débat mais
soutenue par le président américain Joe
Biden arrivé en Israël pour une visite
de
solidarité je suis profondément attristé
et indigné par l'explosion de l'hôpital
de Gaza hier et d'après ce que j'ai vu
il semble que cela a été fait par
l'autre camp pas par vous Joe Biden
devait également participer à un sommet
régional avec plusieurs pays arabes pour
apaiser les tensions il a finalement été
annulé par son hôte la Jordanie au 12e
jour du conflit plus de 3000
Palestiniens et 1400 israéliens sont
morts en majorité des civils alors que
l'ONU appelle à un cesser le feu
immédiat Israël vient d'autoriser
l'entrée d'aide humanitaire dans Gaza
depuis
l'Égypte justement cette aide
humanitaire qui va pouvoir rentrer dans
le sud de la bande de Gaza est
conséquence évidemment de cette frappe
sur l'hôpital de Gaza mais aussi la
visite de Joe Bayen beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder avec mes invités Guillaume Ansel
bonsoir bienvenue ancien officier
écrivain français auteur du blog ne pas
subir Valérie Zenati bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes écrivaine scénariste
traductrice vous connaissez bien la
société israélienne vous y avez vécu
pendant plusieurs années arminearifi
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste grand reporteur au point
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient vous signez
notamment un article dans le magazine de
apparaître demain sur ce conflit
j'accueille également Mathieu croissant
d'au éitoraliste politique bonsoir
Mathie bienvenue à vous on on va
démarrer sur avec des sources d'images
et je vous propose Guillaume mansel
d'essayer de les analyser avec avec nous
donc de cette explosion on est au cœur
de la ville de de Gaza d'abord les
images qui ont été diffusées par tsal
sont des images de nuit il est presque
19h localement par l'armée israélienne
donc on discerne un tir qui semble je
vais être prudent évidemment changer de
direction avant de s'abattre au loin on
voit l'explosion cette boule de feu
apparaître évidemment très lointaine
autre source d'image alors que l'image
alors que le le la caméra zoom voilà une
autre source d'image qu'on vous propose
tout de suite celle-ci elle est diffusée
par un journaliste de la chaîne Catari
aljazira film de beaucoup plus près on
est toujours dans la nuit un peu moins
de 19h l'hôpital est touché une boule de
feu impressionnante que vous allez voir
apparaître sur ces images que vous allez
peut-être entrevu voilà deux sources
différentes il y a pas tant d'images que
ça Guillaume Encel du moment où ça s'est
passé évidemment c'est très compliqué
évidemment on va être prudent évidemment
ça va être une une
bagarre médiatique de communication
pendant les jours et les peut-être les
semaines qui viennent quelle leçon vous
vous tirez de de ces image est-ce que on
peut en déduire quel type d'arme a été
utilisé par exemple ouis en fait moi je
vais pas être prudent et je vais vous
dire qui est à l'origine de cette frappe
h parce qu'en fait on le sait tous c'est
la guerre en réalité il y a il y a deux
versions qui sont parfaitement possible
c'est une explosion de type 200 à 300 kg
ça correspond exact ement à la charge
militaire des missiles Badr qui ont été
livrés par l'Iran aux brigades
islamistes et ça correspond aussi au bon
guidé laser de 250 kg qu'utilise
régulièrement l'armée de l'air
israélienne ce qui veut dire que en
terme de possibilité en réalité ça peut
être exactement l'un ou l'autre et
évidemment aucun d'eux ne va aller
reconnaître avoir fait un truc pareil je
dire ni le Hamas n'acceptera de donner
la moindre preuve parce qu'il reste des
pièces en réalité sur ce qui s'est passé
il reste toujours des traces ni les
Israéliens s'ils avaient commis une
telle erreur parce que ça aurait pas été
un ciblage volontaire mais mais c'est la
guerre c'est tellement horrible vous
l'avez très bien dit dans l'introduction
c'est un tournant c'est un désastre et
un tournant c'estd que si la guerre
continue de toute façon actuellement
c'est le peuple palestinien qui va être
dévasté donc la question elle est même
pas de savoir qui est à l'origine de
cette frappe c'est est-ce qu'on accepte
que cette guerre continue une guerre qui
je le rappelle pardon pour mes amis
arabes qui m'ont beaucoup interrogé sur
le sujet é déclenché par le Hamas mais
dans lequel ils ont piégé Israël qui
aujourd'hui ne trouve aucune porte de
sortie pour arriver à dire mais je
m'arrête parce que de toute façon je ne
sais pas détruire le Hamas sans abîmer
le peuple palestinien donc on est dans
une impasse sanglante dans laquelle si
on reste de toute façon ça ne pourra que
se terminer par un embrasement
généralisé parce que tout le monde a
tort h autre témoignage je vais vous
faire réagir à chacun là c'était sur ces
images je vous propose d'entendre
ensemble le porte-parole de l'armée
israélienne car l'armée israélienne elle
a réagi assez vite après cette frappe
pour accuser le Djihad islamique on
l'écoute il était 18h59 lorsqu'une
explosion a été signalée à l'hôpital Ali
Al mamadani dans la ville de Gaza selon
nos informations le Hamas a vérifié les
rapports a compris qu'il s'agissait
d'une roquette ratée du Djihad islamique
et a décidé de lancer une campagne
médiatique mondiale pour cacher ce qui
s'était réellement passé
Valérie Zenati comme beaucoup de de de
pays occidentaux la société comme dans
beaucoup de pays la société israélienne
elle est assez fracturée on l'a vu avec
toutes les manifestations qui ont lieu
contre la politique de netanahou pendant
des des des semaines avant l'attaque
terroriste du ramas est-ce que il y a
une mise en doute de la version
officielle israélienne ce soir est-ce
que ces fractures elles s'expriment
toujours ou au contraire on a un pays
voilà qui s'est qui se lève ensemble et
qui veut se venger
alors non je crois pas qu'on pourrait
dire ça c'estàd autant dans les
premières heures du de cette guerre vous
l'avez rappelit déclencher ce round
comme on dit totalement déclenché par le
Hamas par un acte de barbarie sans nom
c'estàd que là bien sûr nous on est
enfin vous êtes dans l'actualité les
gens qui vivent là-bas ne sont pas dans
l'actualité ils ont ils ont un
calendrier ou une horloge qui s'est
arrêté le 7 octobre à 6h30 du matin et
et ça c'est vraiment important de le
comprendre puisque vous me parlez de la
société israélienne c'est-à-dire que
l'état dans lequel dans dans dans lequel
la société israélienne est aujourd'hui
les fractures existent et et la colère
c'est un peu exprimé aussi contre le
gouvernement mais l'état dans lequel
elle est je crois que personne ne peut
le percevoir c'est celui d'un d'un
traumatisme qui est encore brûlant qui
n'est absolument pas passé et on pourra
malheureusement arriver au 20e jour de
guerre au 30e jour de guerre ce
traumatisme initial les gens enterrent
encore leur mort euh hier ou avanthier
il y a un homme à qui on a annoncé que
sa fille de 8 ans faisait partie des
corps carbonisés qui n'avait pas été
identifié jusque-là parce que c'est très
difficile d'identifier les corps
carbonisés et il a eu cette phrase
terrible en disant je suis soulagée
qu'elle ne soit pas autage à Gaza vous
voyez c'est-à-dire que nous bien sûr on
est à Paris on essaie de comprendre on
dit un tournant je suis même pas sûr que
ce soit un tournant euh vraiment mais
moi je ne suis pas experte militaire euh
ni experte stratégique je m'exe pas en
tant
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir parce
que alors peut-être que c'est une vision
effectivement beaucoup plus lointaine ça
j'en j'en conviens mais le le le le
temps peut estomper l'émotion c'est
horrible ce que je dis mais en tout cas
dans leion et et ces images d'horreur à
Gaza peuvent remplacer celles de du du
carnage de l'attaque terrorist du Hamas
alors ce qui est intéressant dans ce que
vous dites c'est que manifestement et
c'est et c'est absolument atroce
c'estàdire que moi je suis j'ai
l'impression que depuis le 7 octobre
vous savez je Enel quelque sorte ce
conflit je le pense depuis 1987 j'étais
adolescente en Israël au moment de la
première Intifada ça date 1997 je vivais
là-bas et ma conscience politique
générale et globale s'est forgée à
travers ce conflit et depuis j'ai écrit
des livres j'ai écrit j'ai suivi les
accords d'os slow quand j'étais
journaliste il y a 30 ans j'ai écrit une
bouteille dans la mer de Gaza il y a il
y a 20 ans donc ce conflit je le connais
de l'Intérieur y compris quand on ne
parle pas là attention euh on on peut
pas parler d'émotion qui s'estompent
alors qu'il y a des otages israéliens en
Israël que la société israélienne sa il
y a 200 dessens quand je dis ça je parle
plus de l'opinion internationale qui est
évidment mul je parle pas seulement de
la société is concernant l'opinion
publique si on peut parler d'une opinion
publique mondiale ce qui est presque ce
qui est ce qui est absolument tragique
c'est que on a presque l'impression que
certains d'une certaine manière
n'attendaient que ça pour dire ah ben
voilà vous voyez il y a eu des mort oui
il y a 10 jours ah bah 10 jours c'était
il y a 10 jours déjà et donc là Israël
fait et c'est horrible et j'attire
l'attention sur le fait que la personne
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure vous n' n'z
pas dit qui c'était cette personne qui
donnait un bilan et qui disait des têtes
ont été arrachées je pense que c'est un
représentant du Hamas à Gaza qui prenait
la parole il n'était pas présenté comme
tel par l'Agence France Presse et alors
il était je n'ai pas vu de ce comme
comme un témoin comme un témoin je n'ai
pas vu de je n'ai pas vu de de souti on
ne sait pas qui est cet homme en tout
cas si si il y a son nom nous on l'a pas
donné
d'accord je fais confiance à laord
d'accord ce qui est terrible c'est que
là il reprend quelque chose qui s'est
passé en Israël et qui a été vu par les
M tous les médias internationaux c'est
les têtes coupées de ces nourrissons et
donc là on assiste à quelque chose qui
est absolument tragique et effroyable
quand on dit guerre d'image on parle
d'êtres humains qui sont morts et il y a
10 jours des gens sont morts en Israël
la nuit dernière des gens sont morts à
Gaza ce sont tous des civils
manifestement cette catastrophes sans
nom ne devrait pas être instrumentalisé
par une colère qui n'attend que ça je
suis d'accord avec vous mais elle est de
fait et c'est ce que l'on va découvrir
dans notre débat je vous donne la parole
tout de suite une autre réaction celle
du Haut Commissaire des Nations Unies au
droits de l'homme après justement avoir
découvert ces images de l'hôpital de
Gaza les mots me manquent ce soir des
centaines de personnes ont été tuées de
manière horrible lors d'une frappe
massive contre l'hôpital Ali Arab dans
la ville de Gaza notamment des patients
des professionnels de santé et des
familles qui cherchaient refuge dans et
autour de l'hôpital encore une fois les
plus vulnérables c'est totalement
inacceptable armif est-ce que vous
parlez vous aussi d'un d'un tournant
dans ce dans cette guerre au niveau
médiatique et dans le monde arabe
certainement en Occident à juste titre
on a été tous frappé par les massacres
la tente terroriste commis par par le
Hamas contre une majorité de civil
euh il faut dire que moi je reviens du
Liban
euh intéressant de noter que beaucoup de
personnes AC qui j'ai parlé étaient
assez mal à l'aise avait du mal à
condamner attention je ne suis pas en
train de dire c'est bien c'est pas bien
il faut il faut pas mais pourquoi en
raison du contexte en raison du conflit
israël-palestinien en raison de
l'occupation israélienne
il nét pas à l'aise c'estd qu'il ne
condamna
pas dis je trve intéressant je de
justifier ça mais il me disa oui il y a
eu des massacres oui attentat mais des
Palestiniens au cours de ces dernières
décennies des derniers conflits à gaz
par quand mmemé du blocus de Gaza et
ce qu vous disiez tout à l'heure
effectivement le monde arabe et même
au-delà en Occident n'attendait que ça
je pense que c'est vrai l'Occident c'est
peut-être allé allé trop loin mais le
monde arabe a explosé et le Hamas le
savait je ne c'estàdire que il était
évident après ce qu'a fait le Hamas h
qu'il allait avoir une riposte
israélienne tout d'abord des
bombardements peut-être une invasion
terrestre et qu'on allait avoir de
telles images encore une fois je ne suis
pas en train de justifier hein je parle
justement de la guerre et ça et ça ne
dit pas qui a
qui estorigine cette frapp je vais vous
dire une chose je vais pas vous dire peu
importe mais aux yeux de l'opinion
publique dans la région c'est Israël et
ça sera Israël ou aux yeux et ça c'est
encore plus intéressant des pays arabes
sunnites modérés alliés des États-Unis
dont certains ont reconnu Israël c'est
Israël pour leur communiqué dans la rue
non et dans les communiqués aussi
peut-être un peu sous la pression de la
rueun certainement certainement que ça
joue mais c'est Israël c'està-d
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à un
bouleversement HM
géopolitique dans la région avec des
pays qui ont rétabli leur relation avec
Israël ou qui étaient en voie de
rétablissement qui sont obligé de se
positionner sous la pression énorme
énorme de la rue qui ne comprend pas qui
ne comprend pas et qui dénonce un deux
poids de mesure un double standard de
l'Occident des États-Unis par rapport à
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui donc en ce
sens ce qui est arrivé hier et déjà
d'une certaine manière en tout cas au
niveau médiatique une défaite
israélienne et le Hamas le sait
pertinemment de là à dire que le Hamas
quand il a déclenché cette opération
qu'il a terroriste qu'il a préparé
pendant longtemps maintenant depuis
longtemps on le sait qu'il avait
peut-être calculé sur le coup d'après le
coup d'après on y est aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que au niveau médiatique en
dépit des démentis peut-être des preuves
on ne sait pas on verra Israël et sur le
ban des accusés Israël est acculé
maintenant dernière chose on va parlé de
la guerre de la guerre qui a lie depuis
maintenant 10 jours pas oublier que
aujourd'hui en tout cas d'après ce que
dit le Premier ministre netanahou on va
vers une invasion terrestre c'est-à-dire
que le dur de la guerre n'a pas encore
commencé on est que conna ravoir les
Bombard ou pardon nous interromp on va
venir là-dessus euh je vous propose
effectivement on va rester encore un
moment sur la question des des preuves
même si on comprend bien que ce sera
très difficile sans doute hein d'en
avoir et sur la réaction américaine vous
avez commencé à l'évoquer parce que
cette frappe elle intervient quelques
heures avant l'arrivée de Joe Biden sur
le sur le sol israélien Joe Biden qui
est donc on a déjà vu l'image tout à
l'heure mais elle est vraiment
importante je pense que ça mérite d'être
revisionné ensemble le président
américain est avec le Premier ministre
israélien voici ce que dit Joe
Biden je suis profondément attristé et
indigné par l'explosion de l'hôpital de
Gaza hier et d'après ce que j'ai vu il
semble que cela a été fait par l'autre
camp pas par vous
euh Guillaume Ansel euh est-ce est-ce
qu'on peut espérer avoir des preuves
fiable de l'origine de ce tir en fait
Joe Biden repose sur les renseignements
américains et comme il a une couverture
satellitaire et à mon avis d'avion qui
trace et qui monitore ce qui se passe
au-dessus du ciel de la bande de Gaza
ils ont vu qu'effectivement il y a pas
eu de tir israélien de tir de missile et
par contre ils ne sont pas capables de
voir parce que ça ne se voit pas sur une
couvert aérienne s'il y a eu un tir de
bomb guidé laser et par contre ce qu'ils
ont vu sur leurs images à eux c'est le
tir du missile du sud de la bande de
Gaza celui qui est sur l'image qui est
pas contesté mais c'est impossible avec
les éléments qu'on a de dire si c'est la
charge militaire de ce missile qui est
tomber effectivement sur l'hôpital effit
désastreux mais comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure c'est le propre de la
guerre c'estàdire de toute façon ça ne
pouvait se terminer que de cette
manièreou mais si si pardon oui mais si
on en avait rapidement alors je je
j'imagine pas les les opinions publiques
des pays arabes dont on parlait se se
retourner de du du jour au lendemain
mais ça pourrait voilà altérer un peu
cette C personne ne les croirait en fait
la seule le seul moyen de d'investiguer
sur le sujet ce serait qu' a une équipe
d'enquêteurs qui a rrouver des morceaux
de l'explosif et qui puisse dire ce sont
des pièces d'un missile Badre ou ce sont
des pièces d' bombe guidé laser qui sont
très différentes ça supposerait rentrer
dans Gaza pour le faire évidment ça Nar
c'est Hamas c'est le Hamas qui dirige la
situation sur le terrain donc ils vont
pas se tirer une balle dans le pied en
disant ah bah attendez l'erreur vient de
notre côté on aurait jamais dû faire ça
c'est impossible et les Israéliens même
si d'un seul coup il réalisait Queen
fait il y a eu un drone qui a tiré une
bombe guidé laser un drone ce serait un
drone à haute altitude mais qui avait
tiré cette bombe guidé laser qui est
Intraçable en fait il y a queeux qui
peuvent le savoir mais s'ils la prennent
dans les jours qui viennent ils vont
sûrement pas aller l'annoncer sur la
place publique en tout cas moi je serai
à leur place je le ferai pas donc on ne
le saura pas en tout cas pas dans un
temps assez court pour pouvoir dire aux
opinions c'est ça qui s'est passé tout
ce qu'on peut leur dire c'est qu'en fait
cette guerre elle est vouée à l'échec
oui et par conséquent ça on ne peut pas
avancer sur ce conflit puisque la
deuxième phase qui est prévue par les
militaires israéliens en tout cas
affiché par le gouvernement néaniaou
c'est une invasion terrestre et ça se
terminera exactement de la même manière
al oui ce que je voulais dire c'est que
donc encore une fois moi je suis pas
experte mais en revanche je connais très
bien ces deux sociétés et je et les
perceptions qu'elles ont vous savez
parfois il y a les faits on le voit bien
là il y a un fait personne ne ni qui un
hôpital a été touché à des et puis
ensuite il y a l'interprétation et la
perception des faits qui est parfois
plus importante moi ce que j'ai envie
j'ai envie de souligner plusieurs choses
sur la question de la perception et de
ce qu'en temps de guerre on on reçoit
comme message on va dire de l'ennemi ou
ce que l'ennemi peut sur le 7 octobre il
y a aucun débat c'est le Hamas qui a
commis les massacre au vu et au suus de
tout le monde il ne s'est pas caché de
cette horreur il a pas dissimulé cette
cette horreur au contraire il a diffusé
il a diffusé quand le ramas diffuse ses
images il diffuse une volonté et une
jubilation
euh atroce de la mort de l'ennemi là si
Israël avait envie d'exterminer les
Palestiniens on pourrait dire qu'il
ferait la même chose il dirait alors il
dirait il dirait non non mais je vais
vers une logique de ce qu'est la
l'expression de la haine et du désir
d'extermination
et du désir d'extermination personne ne
dit là chouette on a tué vous voyez et
personne ne son en orgueilli l'autre
chose que les gens savent c'est que
Israël a demandé l'évacuation des
populations civiles non non attendez je
vais vous dire je parle de la perception
je suis pas en train de défendre Israël
je vous dis je parle encore une fois de
la perception de toute façon de toute
façon d'un côté on a une démocratie
certainement imparfaite comme beaucoup
de démocratie mais il nempêche que on
peut imaginer ce qui politiquement va
arriver à benamin netanou dans quelques
mois et de une organisation terroriste
pense par perception c'estd pour les
Isra par mais sur le sur le sur le la
capacité d'évacuation c'est quand même
d'un cinisme absolu parce que où
peuvent-ils partir alors ils sont ils
sont à ils sont à rones et je connais
personnellement et c'est là que je que
que que pour moi c'est pas abstrait je
connais personnellement une
femme une amie là à Paris dont les
enfants sont dont les petits enfants
sont à ils sont tous évatués à à
hananunz depuis plusieurs jours elle n'a
pas de nouvelles elle au aujourd'hui
elle se pose même plus la question de
savoir qui a tiré elle veut savoir
comment vont ces petits enfants euh ils
sont à 20 dans deux pièces ils sont tous
entassés à ranounes il y a des centaines
de milliers de gens qui sont allés se
réfugier dans le clamp de ragounes c'est
absolument terrible pour cette
population qui paye encore une fois le
prix de ce qu'a fait le ramas je dis je
ce que je vous dis là juste puisque vous
me parlez de la société c'est que les
Israéliens perçoivent ça comme une
guerre qui est finalement on parle
toujours d'asymétrie h mais qui est à à
plusieurs asymétries si j'ose dire il y
a une asymétrie entre le ramas et Israël
concernant les moyens militaires
évidemment Israël a une force de frappe
beaucoup plus grande il y a une
asymétrie aussi dans les déclarations
d'intention et dans le message qui est
passé euh en face même si évidemment
aujourd'hui pour tous les palestinens de
Gaza
euh la seule chose qu'il souhait c'est
que ces bombardements cessent et c'est
une évidence et c'est ce qu'on peut leur
souhaiter on par on parle des
bombardements il faut même pas oublier
que avant l'hôpital déjà ce même hôpital
a déjà été la cible de tir israélien
cette fois ça a été confirmé il n'a fait
que des blessés il y a quelques jours et
que le sud du pays parce que cet
hôpital se situe dans le Nord que donc
is dans la V dans la ville de Gaza voilà
donc Israël a appelé à l'évacuation un
hôpital c'est difficile mais que dans le
sud du pays où se trouve une majorité de
déplacés Palestiniens Gazaoui le Sud
n'est pas épargné par les bombardements
dernière chose ça fait 10 jours que
après le 7 octobre les bombardements
aériens de Gaza ont commencé et que
l'aide humanitaire n'a toujours pas pu
rentrer d'après les égyptiens en raison
des bombardements israélien oui le le
post frontière de oui ça été annoncé en
finmi le poste frontière DEFA notamment
a été bombardé plusieurs fois
effectivement donc comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure où peut aller cette
population ça fait quand même Gaza n
apprend pas ce que c'est Gaza Gaza le
blocus illégal de Gaza israélien et
égyptien il a quand même depuis
2000 7 si je ne m'abuse donc 2007 ça
fait calcule 15 ans 16 ans 16 ans ou 15
16 ans ou oui 16 ans exactement
euh il est illégal c'est une prison à
ciel ouvert ça allait enfin où peuvent
aller ces gens ça fait partie des
données du problème et le Hamas le
savait pertinemment évidemment Mathieu
vouliez intervenir i de
d'une façon générale est-ce que tout le
monde est d'accord pour ce pour dire que
ce tir n'était pas intentionnel est-ce
que en gros c'est une soit une erreur du
jjihad islamique soit une erreur
d'Israël peut-être gu làdus oui
absolument c'est typique alors pardon
mais ce genre de de frappe et
d'explosion c'est typique d'une erreur
c'estàd que soit c'est un missile tiré
par les brigal évidemment il visaient
pas leur hôpital soit c'est une bombe
guidé laser israélienne et en fait il
traçait un véhicule qui les intéressait
et ils avaient peut-être que cette
munition là et ils ont pas compris de
nuit que ben en fait ils étaient sur un
hôpital je vais poser la question de
Mathieu différment qui a le plus intérêt
à ce que cette frappe a eu lieu
Guillaume mansel ah en fait est-ce que
c'est pas plutôt le Hamas pour mobiliser
la rue la rue arabe pardon je vais
répondre en sens inverse ceux qui payent
le plus cher sont les Palestiniens oui
d'accord parce que eux de toute façon
quoi qu'il arrive c'est eux qui qui
morfle aujourd'hui d'une manière
hallucinante parce que même sans cette
frappe on est déjà àprès 3000 morts il
faut multiplier par 4 le nombre de
blessés et donc la la question c'est est
oui mais vousz vous l'avez dit vous-même
le Hamas quand il déclenche le l'attaque
terroriste du du 7 octobre il sait très
bien ce qui va se passer après pour la
population palestinenne Israël est tombé
dans un piège on voit bien que cette
guerre de toute façon n'est pas gagnable
uniquement par des moyens militaires et
je pense que c'est là où le Hamas
voulait l'emmener et maintenant Israël
est face à un mur c'estàd qu'elle a pas
de stratégie pour détruire le Hamas et
elle réalise que si elle continue sur le
territoire palestinien en dehors de
soulever les opinions publiques arabes
contre elle et peut-être de déclencher
un conflit régional elle est dans une
impace et le la question pour eux qui
est centrale c'est comment est-ce que
ils arrivent d'un côté à détruire la
masse mais en fait c'est pas ça la
question essentielle c'est l'avenir du
peuple palestinien tant qu'on l'aura pas
réglé cette guerre là elle se reproduira
tous les 3 ans ouis allez je reprends je
pense que tout le monde va intervenir
mais je vais reprendre la main parce
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de question à
à aborder et on va parler maintenant du
Djihad islamique puisque c'est le Djihad
islamique qui est pointé du droit par
euh l'armée israélienne sur la
responsabilité de de cette frappe je
propose à Marion Vigreux de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
avec Marion bonsoir Marion bienvenue à
vous vous allez nous nous expliquer ce
ce qu'est le Djihad islamique
palestinien trois lettre c'est ça c'est
un mouvement révolutionnaire qui a été
fondé à la fin des années 70 au début
cette organisation était proche des
Frères musulmans mais peu à peu ces
fondateurs s'en sont détachés estimant
que les Frères musulmans ne
s'investissaient pas suffis amment dans
la lutte pour la libération de la
Palestine alors l'objectif de ce groupe
c'est l'établissement d'un État
islamique palestinien sur le territoire
historique de la Palestine et pour cela
il prôent la destruction de l'État
d'Israël par rapport au fata et au Hamas
le Djihad islamique est présenté comme
un électron libre contrairement au Hamas
il n'a aucune véléité politique il se
concentre sur la lutte armée on lui doit
plusieurs attentats suicide mais
également tir de roquette contre Israël
il est basé dans la bande de Gaza mais
depuis 2021 c'est aussi l'un des
principaux acteurs de la lutte armée en
6 Jordanie le mouvement est très
populaire auprès des des jeunes il
capitalise notamment sur le discrédit de
l'Autorité palestinienne et évidemment
il y a des synergies avec le Hamas et la
cause qu'il porte dépasse les frontières
de la Palestine oui ils sont dans une
dimension révolutionnaire islamique
globale et ils mènent des combats hors
des frontières de la Palestine il ment
d'ailleurs pour une contagion du conflit
au paysvoisin ces derniers sont proches
du Hezbollah ils sont présents au Liban
en Syrie mais surtout ils ont des liens
très importants avec l'Iran et ne
cachent pas d'ailleurs leur fascination
pour le chiisme révolutionnaire iranien
et à propos de cette relation je vous
propose d'écouter le chercheur David
Rigou les rosé l'organisation oui est
très liée à l'Iran puisque euh son
secrétairegénéral d'ailleurs Z el zakale
est régulièrement régulièrement en Nant
il était encore en juin dernier et
d'ailleurs à cette occasion il avait il
avait euh
explicitement formuler le fait que le le
temps de la de la trêve était révolu et
que celui de la
confrontation
ouverte é était devenu d'actualité et
que ça se ferait évidemment avec on va
dire l'onction du Guide suprême auquel
il se réfère en terme d'autorité
spirituelle et géopolitique et c'est
d'ailleurs l'Iran qui financerait
principalement le Djihad islamique
palestinien un groupe qui a été placé
sur la liste des organisations
terroristes par de nombreux pays
occidentaux les États-Unis l'Union
européenne le Japon et évidemment Israël
merci Marion pour toutes ces information
guillaumel je je reviens vers vous la
puissance militaire du Djihad islamique
c'est c'est quoi en comparaison par
exemple du du ramas alors pour moi c'est
très peu par rapport au has c'est une
armée beaucoup moins importante qui a
réussi à avoir un soutien fort de l'Iran
mais l'Iran ayant toujours joué sur des
concurrences assez intéressantes
notamment entre le Hamas et et les
brigard islamique je dirais plutôt que
il jouent un rôle de
challenger morbide en fait avec le Hamas
parce que c'est contre notamment qu' a
été mené une opération la dernière
opération d'Israël en mai juste avant
l'été et et on voit bien que à ce
moment-là le Hamas s'était gardé de
riposté et que les brigades islamiques
essayent de montrer que c'est eux qui
étaient capable de guider la résistance
donc il a il y a une question aussi de
comment dire de leadership que voudrait
incarner ces deux mouvements en allant
toujours plus loin dans la violence pour
montrer que seul eux sont capables de
mener cette résistance de la Palestine
et qui emmène la Palestine dans une
impasse aussi grande que l'absence de
stratégie du gouvernement netaniaou
arminfi il y a effectivement une sorte
de concurrence aujourd'hui la question
palestinienne et puis plus tard on
reparlera on va de nouveau utiliser ces
mots processus de paix qu'on n pas
utilisé depuis depuis des années mais la
question palestinen est de nouveau au
cœur de des préoccupations diplomatiques
internationales est-ce qu'il y a une
concurrence entre ces mouvements
palestinien terroriste pour
certains pour incarner le leadership
comme ditcel est-ce que c'est aussi à ça
qu'on assiste pas de vélité non du
Djihad islamique de diriger
politiquement du moins la bande de Gaza
non dihad islamique c'est un mouvement
qui ne reconnaît au bien titre que le
hamass pas du tout l'État d'Israël à la
différence de l'Autorité palestinienne
et qui reconna pas qui veut détruire ve
détruire également tout à fait et qui
est pour la lutte armée à 100 % moi ce
qui me ce qui me désole dans ce qui se
passe les les morts civiles sont
terribles un mort est un mort h mais ces
bombardem israélien vont être un vivier
de recrutement énorme pour ces
organisations armées à un point que vous
ne pouvez pas imaginer une nouvelle
spirale de de violence et de vengeence
qui se qui s'enclenche moi effectivement
au printemps dernier pour mon magasine
le point je me suis rendu en cis
Jordanie 6is Jordanie où l'autorité
comme le disait Macon sœur Autorité
palestinienne de Mahmoud Abbas qui a
officiellement renoncé à la lutte armée
qui qui est complètement discrédité
parce que en 20 ans elle n'a strictement
rien obtenu au niveau politique ni
diplomatique de la part d'Israël au
contraire la colonisation israélienne
n'a fait que se renforcer les violences
des colons il faut le rappeler il y a eu
quand même environ 250 morts palestinens
depuis le début de l'année par les
violences des colons mais également je
parle de la sise Jordanie pas de Gaza de
l'autre côté mais également de la part
de l'armée israélienne ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que cette frustration
de la part de la jeunesse qui ne voit
aucun avenir et qui aspire simplement à
vivre libre mais également à vivre avoir
une situation d'cence au niveau
économique est un vivier de recroutement
parce que quand je me suis rendu sur
place j'ai parlé avec des responsables
locaux du Djihad islamique notamment en
aplous et il me disait vous pouveaz pas
savoir à quel point aujourd'hui les
jeunes se tournent vers nous pourquoi
parce que on a les armes on a d'un côté
et je fais mais c'est l'Iran qui vous
qui vous finance n'est-ce pas il me fait
mais écoutez on a d'un côté l'Iran qui
nous dit continuez la lutte armée on va
vous payer on va vous donner encore
davantage d'armes et de l'autre des pays
comme l'Arabie Saoudite qui sont en
train de normaliser avec l'État hébreux
qui nous disent renoncez à la lutte
armée engagez-vous dans un processus
politique dont vous savez au passage qui
ne mènera nulle part et reconnaissez
l'État d'Israël bah vous pensez que les
gens viennent continuer la lutte armée
parce que c'est la lutte armée qui
apporte qui qui qui qui donne un un
rapport de force et là-dessus
l'opération du Hamas il ne faut pas il
faut voir aussi ce côté des choses bien
sûr qu'elle est terrible qu'elle est
terroriste que c'est un massacre de
civil avec des images qui font froid
dans le dos mais de l'autre il y a
aujourd'hui une organisation le Hamas
qui dans l'imaginaire des Palestiniens
réussi à briser le siège de Gaza a brisé
le blocus vous ne pouvez pas savoir à
quel point les gens ont halluciné quand
ils voyaient des images de combattants
palestinien sur la terre d'Israël
traverser la frontière prendre des
selfies
vueétait la réité pvez Pasir àel dans la
région Paron est quand même on parle du
Pr Orient ce qui est arrivé est un
bouleversement terrible et à quel point
aujourd'hui le Hamas en tout cas au
niveau politique est au top de sa forme
même si G est train d'être détruit bien
sûr au détriment de la population
effectivement on a déjà dit sur ce
plateau mais y a une part d'échec de
benamin netanahou sur sur cette question
là vous parliez de la colère qui s'est
exprimé dans les dans les premiers jours
il y a une partie de la des civils
israéliens qui se sont sentis quoi
abandonnés et totalement isolés face à
ce qui se passait il y a deux choses et
enfin je vous rejoins sur beaucoup de
choses qui Vinent d'être dites et j'y
arriverai peut-être justement en vous
répondant c'est que on on on le sait il
y a un gouvernement en place depuis près
d'un an qui a entrepris de saper les
fondements de la démocratie et du
système de justice en Israël et et qui a
soulever une opposition extrêmement
forte tenace à l'israélienne si j'ai
envie de dire parce que aen on un côté
tétu on ne bouge pas on ne bouge pas on
ne bouge pas parfois c'est désespérant
mais là 500000 personnes dans les rues
chaque semaine dans un pays de 9
millions d'habitants pour dire non à
cette réforme c'était absolument
incroyable pendant ce temps et ça je
l'ai entendu je l'ai lu je le suivez des
hauts responsables militaires des haut
responsables des services de sécurité
alerter netaniaahou le le le chef
d'état-major lui-même a voulu l'alerter
en juillet en disant que la réforme de
la justice mettait en péril la Sécur
d'Israël il ne disait pas l'équilibre
intérieur la paix civile non il disait
la sécurité pourquoi parce qu'il avait
tous les éléments en main pour savoir on
va pas épilogier là-dessus mais il y
avait déjà cette alerte c'est tous les
manifestants savaient que il mettait
Israël en
danger parce que ce cette fracture
provoquait aussi une fracture à
l'intérieur des services secrets et
cetera et autrre la deuxième chose et la
colère qui est là et qui est vive c'est
que le matin de l'attaque et dans tous
les jours qui ont suivi à partir de 7
octobre le gouvernement israélien a
répondu aux abonnés absents nataniaahou
s'est contenté d'une vague vidéo où il a
dit nous sommes en guerre nous les
aurons jusqu'au dernier samedi 7 octobre
alors que des gens étaient encore à
l'intérieur de chez eux en train de
brûler vif et appelé à l'aide il n'a pas
eu un mot pour dire aux gens qui étaient
en train de se faire de se faire
massacrer nous allons venir vous sauver
nous sommes là ils ne sont pas descendus
dans le sud ils ont mis beaucoup de
temps mais ils n'y sont pas allés
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent très bien
et et et là c'est intéressant enfin
c'est c'est tragique mais ils savent
très bien qu'ils vont se faire recevoir
par la population comme ils se sont fait
recevoir dans certains hôpitaux par une
population qui très souvent a voté pour
eux dans le sud du pays très souvent il
faut savoir que cette population depuis
que le ramas est au pouvoir vit les tir
des missiles de roquettes parfois
quotidiennement et personne n'en parle
en Israël à taviv les gens vivent
tranquillement ils vont dans des
restaurants ils travaillent ils vont
dans des cafés cette population vit ça
quotidiennement netanahou a promis la
sécurité à Israël et cette histoire vous
les avez raison c'est une victoire
éclatante pour le ramas cette histoire
enfin je ve dire cette histoire cette
attaque et la preuve éclatante aussi que
natanahou a n'a pas apporté la
destruction le lapsus révélateur n'a pas
apporté la sécurité et son gouvernement
d'extrême droite mais au contraire la
destruction donc la colère elle est là
et pour longtemps allez on va reparler
de de diplomatie pour terminer ce débat
un long chapitre consacré à la visite de
Joe Biden en en en Israël Mathieu on va
commencer avec vous quel bilan vous
pouvez tirer de cette visite du
président américain ben pour faire le
bilan faut souvenir des des objectifs
qui étaient affichés par par Joe Biden
le premier c'était un objectif de
solidarité après les attaques les plus
meurtrières qui est connu l'État hébreux
sur son sol depuis sa création et là on
a eu droit à une longue accolade de de
de Joe Biden avec Benjamin netaniaahou
la dénonciation des atrocités commises
par le Hamas selon Biden qui ferait
passer l'état islamique pour un
mouvement plus raisonnable a-t-il dit
donc cette première case elle est coché
solidarité d'abord soutien ensuite la
présence de Biden à Tel Aviv avait pour
objectif dit-il d'envoyer un signal au
peuple israélien mais aussi au peuple du
monde afin qu'il sacheent quelle est la
position des États-Unis bon il y avait
peu de suspense mais cette visite elle
avait donc une valeur d'avertissement à
tous les acteurs de la région qui
pourrait être tenté par une escalade
notamment l'Iran on en parlait le
hzbolah la Syrie qui sait et afin de
montrer qu'il ne bluffe pas ben Biden a
envoyer on le sait deux pores-avion un
croiseur des destroyers une puissance de
feu assez considérable il ajouté par
ailleurs aujourd'hui qu'il s'assurait
personnellement qu'Israël dispose bien
de ce dont il a besoin sous-entendu en
terme logistique ou militaire donc là
pour le coup le soutien ça a été salué
évidemment par benjamine netaniaahou la
case est cochée aussi la troisème case
c'était l'humanitaire on s'en souvient
avec notamment la volonté d'obtenir un
corridor j' vaais dire permanent pour
permettre à l'aide humanitaire de de
venir là pour le coup c'est en
demiteinte parce que le l'ouverture elle
va se faire ça a été annoncé par Israël
aujourd'hui via le poste frontière de de
de Rafa côté côté égyptien pas côté
israélien RZ bien sûr mais j'ai pas
compris qu'il s'agirait d'un corridor
permanent ou de quelque chose qui
permettrait de ravitailler sur le long
terme la bande de Gaza et puis s'il
s'agissait enfin donc la la case elle
est cochée mais on va dire à moiti et
puis s'il s'agissait de dessiner des
perspectives ou à minima de calmer le
jeu B al faut dire que Joe Biden a fait
chou blanc est vraiment de sa faute non
on se souvient
que le l'explosion hier à l'hôpital de
Gaza a fait annuler le sommet qu'il
avait prévu avec les dirigeants arabes
qui devaient se dérouler en Jordanie les
dirigeants arabes mais aussi
marmoudabbasin de de l'Autorité
palestinienne et puis
euh pour calmer ou convaincre les les
Palestiniens euh là aussi il a fait
choublanc alors il a dit euh il faut
distinguer selon lui les le Hamas des
Palestiniens il s'est déclaré on l'a vu
indigné attristé par l'explosion de de
l'hôpital mais on l'a vu aussi il a
dédoiné Israël de toute responsabilité
dans cette explosion avec quelle
réaction dans la foulée avec une
réaction du Hamas d'être traité de
complice des massacres israéliens dans
la bande de Gaza h merci Mathieu pour
toutes ces informations al beaucoup
d'éléments sur lesqueles on peut
reprendre je vrais démarrer par l'aide
humanitaire
arminarfi qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi eau
nourriture médicament c'est ce qui a été
annoncé par le gouvernement israélien on
n'est pas encore effectivement dans un
corridor humanitaire tel qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer non effectivement c'est
exactement ça ce sont les les les les
les les aliments de de base et il faut
pas oublier aujourd'hui que
l'électricité est coupée aujourd'hui
désormais dans le sud il n'y a plus les
générateurs ne fonctionnent plus car il
n'y a plus d'électricité et que Gaza est
coupé du monde donc il y a urgence y
compris dans les hôpitaux alchifa euh le
plus grand de Gaza où
les les les les les médecins opèent dans
le noir sans électricité c'est quand
même
effroyable et de l'autre se pose ensuite
la question don qu'on évoqué tout à
l'heure à savoir qu des civil il y a eu
au départ une proposition qui a été vécu
dans le monde arabe comme une comme une
provocation celle du ministre Nuf Galand
de la Défense israélien à savoir de
reloger pour un un certain temps les
habitants de Gaza dans le Sinaï égyptien
dans le désert du Sinaï ce qui a été ce
à quoi a
catégoriquement ce que ce qu' a
catégoriquement refusé l'Égypte en
évoquant en disant que c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé au cours des
précédentes Guer et qui a qui qui a
abouti
à l'exil de un certain nombre de
Palestiniens que ce soit au Liban en
Syrie ils ne sont jamais revenu on
connaît la suite mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment le boulversement géopolitique
et une sorte de de division au sein même
du camp américain bien sûr on a un
soutien indéfectible des États-Unis qui
ont
donné toute l'attitude à Israël pour
répondre mais c'est également le cas au
niveau des au niveau des pays
occidentaux européens la France par
exemple on s aujourd'hui France est gêné
aux entournures h
entre le fait de souligner le droit à
Israël de se défendre et de l'autre
timidement demander à l'armée
israélienne de respecter le droit
humanitaire et ça ça fait mouche encore
une fois auprès des opinions arabes qui
estiment que l'Occident n'est plus
légitime pour servir pour dicter le
tempo politique dans la région et c'est
là que ça fait le jeu de pays comme
l'Iran comme la Russie comme la Chine
qui font
qui font vre de bons offices pour
essayer de régler la situation encore
une fois le plus intéressant aujourd'hui
est-ce que netanahou peut se permetre de
ne pas lancer d'offensive terrestre je
ne suis pas certain auprès de l'opinion
les ages oui bien sr sur pardon je
reprends la ces enjeux diplomatiques
parce que je vis qu'on
entende Mahmoud Abbas puisqueil y avait
un sommet quadripartide qui devait se
tenir en Jordanie à Aman avec le roi de
Jordanie avec le le président égyptien
et avec Mahmoud Abas le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne qui a renoncé
il explique
pourquoi face à la tragédie qui s'est
déroulée ce soir et afin de protéger
notre peuple j'ai décidé d'interrompre
ma visite à Aman et de revenir au pays
pour être au côté de mon peuple dans
cette grande
épreuve j'ai convenu avec les frères
jordaniens et égyptiens d'annuler le
sommet qui était prévu à Haman
aujourd'hui avec le président
Biden Guillaume Ansel c'est aussi une
occasion manquée pour Marmoud Abbas on
parlait de de du fait que l'autorité
palestinen était discréditée depuis des
mois pour ne pas dire des des années
auprès des Palestiniens il y avait là
une volonté de le faire ressurgir d'une
certaine façon comme un interlocuteur
clairement c'est c'est un échec aussi et
à mon avis c'est une alternative sans
issue on va pas reconstruire la
crédibilité de Mahamou Abbas qui est un
très vieux dirigeant qui a montré que il
était pas capable d'apporter quoi que ce
soit au peuple palestinien qui s juste
un peu enrichi au passage et par
conséquent je pense que vis-à-vis du
peuple palestinien il il ne comment dire
il ne représente plus aucun avenir par
contre ce qui est inquiétant c'est le
fait qu'il ait pas pu y avoir de
rencontrre notamment entre Joe Biden et
les principaux dirigeants arabes parce
que là c'était une occasion d'esquisser
un avenir en fait une sortie de ce
conflit tout à l'heure on parlait des
corridors humanitaires vous savez les
corridors humanitaires c'est un faux
semblant dans cette situation là c'est
juste une manière de ne pas regarder la
réalité la réalité c'est que tant que la
guerre contre la bande de Gaza continue
pour les Palestiniens c'est l'horreur
assurée qui a un corridor humanitaire ou
pas et chaque fois que quelqu'un nous
annonce qu'il va y avoir un corridor
humanitaire il oublie qu'il y a deux
autres acteurs parce qu'ils sont trois
en fait à jouer sur le sujet il y a bien
sûr les Israéliens qui bombardent qui
bombardaient encore avanttiier le le la
porte de Rafa enfin la région il y a les
Égyptiens qui disent enfin qui à ma
connaissance de sources bien informé en
Égypte on dit ils ont déposé des plots
de béton pour bien montrer qu'ils avait
aucune intention qu'on ouvre le corridor
et puis évidemment donc il y a une sorte
de double langage c'est que l'Égypte
vair le le le le peuple palestinien mais
refuse de l'accueillir cô absolument et
il y a le côté Hamas qu on a pas du tout
l'assurance qui laisse partir les
Palestiniens parce que ils leur serent
de boucliers humain et donc ils savent
que si jamais le peuple palestinien
partait alors le Hamas pourrait partir
avec lui hein ça c'est encore un autre
sujet mais pour moi cette histoire de
corridor humanitaire vous savez c'est
euh comment dire c'est quand on veut se
se camoufler parce que on ose plus
regarder la réalité et la réalité c'est
que cette guerre n'est pas
tenable dernier mot Valérie Zenati sur
Leon va parler du soutien militaire
américain dans dans quel état
d'esprit sont les militaires israéliens
et notamment ceux parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de jeunes réservistes qui
faisaient partie des manifestants dont
vous nous parliez tout à l'heure qui qui
étaient opposés au au gouvernement
netaniaahou à sa réforme de de la
justice au au bloutoir qu' donnait à la
démocratie de leur de leur pays il y a
quoi il y a malgré tout un réflexe
patriotique qui qui joue ou alors il y a
des réfractaires quand même oh non il y
a je crois qu'il y a très RCT je sais
même pas si c'est un réflexe patriotique
enfin alors je sais que c'est sans comme
unee mesure mais il faut dire que Israël
continue d'être bombardé par le Hamas
hier avant-hier il y a des tir de
missile de roquettes jusqu'à telavive
c'est les Israéliens ne font pas la
guerre tout seul ils sont attaqués de
leur côté il y a le hbollah qui teste
les Israéliens chaque jour avec des des
tirs de missilees antiank euh il y a une
menace d'embrasement qui est absolument
terrifiante et je pense vraiment
qu'aujourd'hui de ce que je vois et
entends ceux qui sont mobilisé sont
aussi dans un réflex de survie de
protéger les leurs et leur pays c'est
même plus du patriotisme c'est plus de
la politique c'est simplement une
question de survie Israël est en guerre
le Hamas a déclaré la guerre Israël le
Hezbollah va peut-être lui emboiter le
pas ou pas on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer dans les territoirees
Palestiniens il y a eu plus d'une
vingtaine de Palestiniens tués la
semaine dernière on a du mal à suivre
tous les bilans mais en réalité enfin je
le dis et c'est pas je on c'est ni en
tournant c'est autre chose c'est quelque
chose de catastrophique qui a en train
de de se produire je dirais juste parce
que mon domaine c'est les mots il y a
deux mots qui ressurgissent côté
israélien et côté palestinien ces
jour-ci côté israélien c'est la Choa
toute proportion gardé évidemment mais
les gens considèrent qu'il y a eu une
Choa à l'échelle des quelques kilomè
Carr attaqué et c'est le mot Nakba qui
ressurgit l'ami palestinienne dont je
parlais tout à l'heure disait voilà ma
famille a quitté Gaza ils n'ont plus que
la clé et la maison est peut-être
détruite c'est-à-dire que ces deux mots
qui sont en quelque sorte fondateur
Nakba ça veut dire quoi Nakba c'est la
catastrophe pour les Palestiniens qui
qui qui a consisté la création de l'État
d'Israël ou le refus du plan de partage
euh en 1947 et 48 et la choix c'est
l'extermination également LEB l'exile
forcé et l'exile forcé oui oui l'il
forcé et la Choa c'est l'extermination
des des Juifs d'Europe moi je con ça
juste he je suis pas en train de faire
de mais je dis que ces deux motsl qui
datent des années 40 ont ressurgi des
deux côtés et c'est très
important on parlait de M là j'ai pensé
à l'Iran
euh euh aujourd'hui il y a le spectre
d'une guerre multifront h et c'est ça
qui terrifie tout le monde à savoir que
l'Iran a clairement l'Iran n'a pas
intérêt à une guerre un conflit direct
avec Israël en revanche l'Iran est en
train de souffler sur les braises l'Iran
est le principal on sait pas si l'Iran
ordonné au Admas de faire ça ou en tout
cas après nos informations ils étaient
au courant si il ce qu'ils ont annoncé
les iraliens c'est que si l'armée
israélienne envahissait Gaza au niveau
terrestre le hzbolla autrement plus fort
que le Hamas avec ses 150 missiles
100000 combattant allit intervenir au
front nord et que d'autres groupes
pro-iraniens des mil chit en Syrie en
Irak ou les rebelles outil au Yémen avec
leur capacité fourni par
l'Iran des roquettes mais également
certains missile balistique pouvait
frapper à leur tour donc on a vraiment
le spectre d'une guerre régionale
espérons qu'on pourra l'éviter merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
jeétais obligé pardon de vous de vous
interrompre c'est d'ailleurs dans cette
perspective aussi que Joe Biden a envoyé
les deux pores-avion dont on a parlé
c'est une démonstration de force très
importante message envoyé notamment à
l'Iran Joe Biden qui a annoncé également
qu'il demanderait cette semaine au
Congrès une aide sans précédent pour
Israël ce sera l'un des enjeux des
prochains jours côté américain dans un
contexte politique très très tourmenté
là-bas aussi merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat arminearfi je
rappelle qu'on vous lit dans le point
euh dans ce numéro apparaître euh demain
dont on va revoir peut-être la
couverture merci à tous en France et
dans le moyen et dans le Moyen-Orient à
bientôt sur public Séna